the minutes after a gunman opened fire
in a Frankfort suburb he targeted a
shisha bar popular with immigrants and
police are now looking into what appears
to be a racist killing spree in the
heart of Germany today the midnight bar
in hano remained sealed off for scenes
of crimes officers scoured the premises
where the first of what would become
nine people died those inside had no
defense against an armed man intent on
killing and maiming interior minister
horsey hopper visited the scene of what
would be just the first horrific attack
in Hanna as the public prosecutor
identified the gunman as Thomas R a 43
year old German who was tracked to this
apartment where he was found dead along
with his 72 year old mother a video
online postings and documents found at
the flat point to what the federal
prosecutor called a deeply racist
mindset he had gone on to target another
location killing four inside this cafe
and shooting another person in a car
saad jan heard the gunfire and rushed
outside he was horrified by what he saw
people he knew lying dead I was in the
house and I heard three shots and I
heard more shots and I ran to the kiosk
and then I saw the injured people locals
came to lay flowers close to the cafe
barely able to believe what had happened
just yards away the body of one of the
victims was being removed as discreetly
as possible the attacks are being
treated as an act of domestic terrorism
German Chancellor Angela Merkel reacting
to the evidence of racist killings much
currently indicates that the perpetrator
acted out far-right racist motives
fueled by hate against
with different backgrounds a different
religion or different appearance racism
is a poison the investigation is now
focusing on whether the gunman acted
alone or whether he had co-conspirators
and supporters the federal police are
examining the video and notes found at
his apartment because Germans
contemplate what looks like homegrown
terrorism the country's president led
the morning at the two sites where
people were killed and injured attacks
which left many immigrants wondering if
they're safe here
Michelle Clifford Sky News Hannah
Germany